book to movie adaptations are tricky to
the point where the phrase the book was
better has become a cliche the book the
disaster artist is one of my favorite
books about filmmaking is about Tommy
was Oh the infamous creator of the room
and it's written by Tommy's best friend
and co-star Greg Sestero
the book is not only the behind the
scenes tale of the making of what has
been dubbed the greatest bad movie ever
made it's the story of the strange
eccentric mysterious man behind the film
so naturally I was interested when I
found out that James Franco was
directing an adaptation of Greg's book
and the first question I had about the
film was what will Tommy think of the
movie we eventually got the answer which
surprised me how closely do you think
James and the story captured your
essence I will say 99.9% since famously
Tommy only approved of Greg's book 40%
the book came out and he called it the
red Bible and then he said he approved
of it 40% so why does Tommy love the
movie and dislike the book is it just
another strange Tommy was out quark I
don't think so and in fact I think the
disparity lies at the heart of why
Franco's movie is not a good adaptation
this video is sponsored by audible when
it comes to adaptations fans often get
upset about small changes or
inaccuracies in a strange way Franco's
movie is obsessed with accuracy on a
detail level many scenes are fairly
close to what's in the book this account
and as the movie proudly shows us at the
end much care was taken to accurately
recreate actual scenes from the room
Franco's performances Tommy is also
surprisingly good it's about as accurate
and embodiment of Tommy as I think we
could ask for and yet to me something
still felt off
[Music]
the disaster artist is accurate on a
micro scale but I think the changes it
does make shifts the heart of the story
in a way that is interesting but
ultimately detrimental to the story the
Tommy Gregg illustrates for us in the
book is difficult to understand and deal
with he's complicated and fascinating
he's a stubborn hopeful who is
mysteriously wealthy Greg's depiction of
Tommy is certainly caring and
sympathetic but it's also laced with
honesty about the darker side of the
story yeah you can say that again and
it's not afraid to criticize it's
subject
Franko's Tommy retains some of these
qualities but he ultimately distills
Tommy down into a sort of underdog hero
Franko's Tommy is a quirky guy who
sticks to his dream and wins against all
odds
Franco's movie celebrates that I think
that he had a very clear vision this art
or the kind of sheer ambition of it is
using incredible sure it highlights some
of the frustrating Tommy moments and the
crews exasperation but it does so mostly
for comedic effect while in the film
tension between Greg and Tommy is a plot
point late in the second act in the book
this tension is at the core of what
makes the story so interesting the movie
displays Greg's participation and
cheerleader attitude without revealing
the internal struggle and self-awareness
that accompanied that
in the movie Greg is simplified to
someone who worships Tommy's
self-confidence 300 miles away we just
don't it would take hours and only
really second-guesses things when Tommy
gets in the way of his career in the
book
Greg refuses to be in the room at first
only eventually giving in much later but
you want me to play Marky nice big role
I have a Johnny Depp about no no no I
want it I want the role missing from the
film is a close examination of Greg why
does Greg knowing things are bad
continue to enable and support Tommy is
he just being a good friend is blindly
encouraging someone when you know what
they're making isn't good being a good
friend Greg even questions himself and
his own motivations throughout the book
we know how the story ends
and so in hindsight it's easy to see
Craig's encouragement as a good thing
but what if the room instead of making
Tommy a cult success had opened him up
to endless ridicule and made him more of
a social outcast than he already was the
movie overlooks some of the darker
themes and trauma that may have led to
Tommy's creation of the room and the
book Tommy disappears for a while and
Greg unable to get in contact with him
is quite worried that something bad may
have happened
Tommy eventually reappears and decides
to film the room but gone from the movie
is Tommy's dark night of the soul it's
reduced to a sort of feel good pep talk
moment remember we said we were gonna
push each other never give up on our
dreams right
and in one of the most totally dissonant
moments I think I've seen in a film in a
while
Franco's movie presents a theater full
of people chanting for a character to
kill themselves and expects us to accept
it as a positive thing
[Applause]
[Applause]
just look at how Greg describes the
story he wants to tell in the book and I
really wanted to tell a story that I
felt like would would honor that I'm not
shrink from the darker moments of that
experience compared with how Franco
describes the story he's trying to tell
in the movie
I read Greg's book and I love Hollywood
stories and I thought this was
incredible you know it was a wild zany
story about making this wild and zany
movie it's about you know outsider
artists trying to make it in this really
difficult business and it really moved
me Greg's book is a tragedy it doesn't
give us the happy ending and we the
audience in hindsight know Tommy will
eventually become accepted and loved
though not in the way Tommy wanted it's
honest about the pain and hardship that
was involved in getting to where things
are today
Franco's movie is a comedy it treats the
story as a classic if you dream big and
work hard you'll succeed story but with
a little twist
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it shows Tommy accepting the backwards
nature of his success without a whole
lot of struggle you think Hitchcock got
a response like this
yeah
while the movie might be accurate about
a lot of things the heart of the story
is completely different I think it's a
poor adaptation in the macro sense this
oversimplification of Tommy into a hero
character I think is obviously at the
heart of Tommy's love for the film Tommy
loves the movie because it presents him
in the best possible light and I get it
it's nice to imagine that we live in a
world where even if you're bad at what
you do you'll still end up successful
famous and happy and that's a fun story
to tell and maybe in this case it's even
the true one there's another piece to
this puzzle the disaster artist book and
movie are both adaptations of real life
so while the movie is partly an
adaptation of the book it's also an
adaptation of Franco's and the writers
perspectives on the real-life story
Greg's book isn't the definitive truth
and it's possible that it's colored
unnecessarily dark by his personal
involvement and subjective experience
this is a revealing example of just how
difficult good adaptation really is I
don't think Franco's movie is a
dishonest adaptation it doesn't lie
about Tommy or the story but personally
I find the book to be much more
interesting and thought-provoking the
movie wants us to believe that there's
something about Tommy that makes the
room not just a terrible movie but
something special and I agree but the
movie only explores Tommy on a surface
level and in a strange way I feel like
it's the sort of plastic fake story that
Tommy himself is so quick to criticize
I originally listened to Greg's book as
an audiobook on a road trip and the trip
went by in a flash
that's why is a perfect sponsor for
today's video the disaster artist is one
of those audiobooks where I can
definitely say that listening to it as
an audiobook is a better experience than
reading the print book Greg Sestero
narrates the audiobook himself and he
does a fantastic impression of Tommy's
voice that's at least as good as
Franco's maybe better it's a hilarious
poignant book that I highly recommend
and you can get it for free when you
sign up for a free 30-day trial of
audible using the link in the
description I would never be able to
read as much as I do if it weren't for
audiobooks and audible is the best way
to get audiobooks I listen to audio
books while I'm cooking falling asleep
driving editing videos and basically
during any activity that doesn't require
me to use my ears audible is offering my
viewers a free audio book with a 30 day
trial membership just go - www-wait or
text Tana sleight - 500 500 and get a
free book they also have a great listing
guarantee so if you don't like a book
you can just swap it out for another one
go to audible.com slash Thomas white or
text Thomas flight - 500 500 and get
your free book if you're new here hit
the subscribe button so you can stay up
to date on my latest videos as always
thank you to my patreon supporters
they're a big part of what makes this
channel possible consider joining their
ranks at patreon.com slash Thomas flight